Welcome students
to the Pharmacology
of the Local Anesthetics.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
Here are the
learning objectives.
I put headings on
each one of them
so that you can
more easily tell
what it is you
need to learn.
Preparation materials.
they strongly
advise you to work
with the materials.
The only thing that
I expect from you is
the practice questions.
You can gather the
new learning any way
you like to do it.
Here are links
to help you
if you wish to use them.
Key points, I put
them into tables
to help separate
the ideas for you.
You can use these key
points as an overview,
can be helpful as
an outline, or as a
summary or something
to help you learn by.
And that brings
us to the lecture.
The local anesthetics
are divided into
two categories the
ester linked and the
amide linked esters
and amides for short
the ester linkage
here the amide
linkage here you
can see it's linking
two components of
the molecule on
this side of this
figure we have an
aromatic ring and
it is lipophilic.
On the other side is
a hydrophilic group
and these characteristics
are important
for the function of
local anesthetics.
We'll begin with a
pharmacokinetics just
because I think of
it this way. First we
have to get the drug
into the patient.
Local anesthetics
are intended to
be used locally as
their name says.
They are usually given
by one bolus injection
into the site of
action and it can be
a small amount or a
larger amount depending
on the type of block
that is intended.
Once at the site of
injection, they're
generally slowly absorbed
into the bloodstream.
So systemic absorption,
as you would expect,
removes the drug from
the site of action
into the bloodstream,
terminates the effect.
and depending on how
much drug enters the
bloodstream, adverse
effects can happen.
The extent of
systemic absorption is
determined by the dose,
the local vascularity,
whether or not a
vasoconstrictor has been
used together with the
local anesthetic, and
of course the properties
of the drug itself.
Local anesthetics
are plasma
and tissue protein bound.
The amide link
anesthetics range from
55 to 95 percent
bound and this is
determined by the
lipophilicity of the drug.
So this is a range
for the amide
local anesthetics
from one to the other.
They bind to a
protein in the plasma
called alpha-1
acid glycoprotein.
This is synthesized
in the liver and
expressed in higher
amounts in people who have
fever, inflammation,
that sort of thing.
now protein binding
we know from our basic
pharmacology lecture
prevents the drug from
being free and only
free drug is available
to go to the site of
action be metabolized etc
I'm sure you remember
that so protein bound
drugs bound to plasma
and tissue proteins
act as a
reservoir, and they
slowly release the drug.
I put this in bold,
this feature here in
bold. Highly lipid
-soluble drugs tend to bind
more tightly to plasma
and tissue proteins,
and we'll see how this
becomes important.
Distribution.
First, the highly
perfused tissues.
We're injecting them
into the body. They'll
enter the bloodstream
at some point.
And they will naturally,
like all drugs,
go to the highly
perfused tissues
first and then to the
moderately perfused
tissues. Now remember,
these drugs have
a certain degree
of lipid solubility
and it depends on
the particular drug.
So what can happen?
first pass extraction.
The lungs have a
high vascularity
and a high surface area.
These lipid soluble
drugs therefore can
will pass through the
lungs first, and a
significant amount of
the molecules of the
dose will be sequestered
in the tissue.
And then, of course,
it goes on to the
highly perfused other
organs. And finally,
on to the less perfused
muscles and fat.
And here's why we
think about that.
Depending, of course,
on the dose, there
is a potential for
organ toxicity with
high local anesthetic
concentrations.
Toxicity.
Metabolism. The
ester-linked ones
are rapidly
metabolized in the
blood by
pseudocolonesterase.
I'm sure you remember
pseudocolonesterase,
also called
plasmacolonesterase, also called
butyrylcholinesterase.
It's all the same thing.
And they are
converted into para
-aminobenzoic acid
paba, which is
inactive. So that
happens rapidly.
The amide link are
oxidized by the hepatic
CYPs. So it takes a
little bit longer. And
the metabolites are
excreted in the urine.
and very little
unchanged drug goes out.
Administration,
topically, by
infiltration directly
into the local area
of the peripheral
nerve endings.
There could
be small areas
where the peripheral
nerves are.
Nerve blocks is injection
into the major
nerve trunks.
Neuraxial block means
it's going
into the spine.
So it's injected
into the tissue
surrounding the
nerve roots, and they
are epidural or
caudal or spinal.
Spinal goes into
the cerebral spinal
fluid surrounding
the spinal cord.
And something
called beer block or
intravenous regional
anesthesia, I think
is a more frequently
used term now.
is intravenous,
and I'll talk more
about that when I
get to the picture.
I've been thinking
intravenous, but aren't
we supposed to be
using them locally?
Here's an example
of a cream
being applied
to the skin.
This is a patch
applied to
the skin, typically
lidocaine,
lidopatch. patch.
And here the topical
anesthetic is being
applied to the mucous
membranes of this,
what appears to be a
child, by the dentist.
The nerve block
will block a
certain set of
nerves. It's injected
into the deeper
tissues and this
is an example of
neuraxial block.
You should be
familiar with this
term, neuraxial
block, where it goes
right into the
spine. And epidural,
caudal, also
paraneural, and spinal.
And finally the
intravenous regional
anesthesia. This It
stays locally because the
tourniquet is first
placed over the upper arm
in order to, in this
picture anyway, over
the upper arm to stop
the flow of blood
into the extremity.
It has to be a fairly
rapid procedure, 45 to
60 minutes, and then
the tourniquet would
be released gradually,
and the local anesthetic
would be gradually
absorbed into the
systemic circulation.
Let's talk about
PKA now. I'm sure
you remember our
friends Henderson
and Hasselbach and
their equation.
These are weak
bases, pKa 7.5 to 9,
depending on the
particular antibiotic.
Now, why is this
important? Well, we're
going to, with the
Anderson-Hasselbach
equation, I put it
in this form, because
we are comparing
the different pKa
values at pH of about
7.4, the same pH.
Why 7.4? Because
that's physiologic pH.
Now,
think about the local
anesthetic that has a
pKa of 7.5. Well, that's
just about 7.4. So
at physiologic pH,
there would be about a
50-50 ratio of ionized
to unionized, right?
Approximately. But
the drug with the
pKa of 9 is going to
have a much higher
concentration of
the protonated form.
So, the local
anesthetic with the pKa
closer to physiologic
pH will have a greater
fraction of the drug
in the uncharged
form than the one
with the higher PKA.
This particular
information is important
because it is the uncharged
form that diffuses
through the nerve
membrane. And the side of
action is inside the
sodium channel on the
cytosolic side. So the
drug has to get through
the membrane in order
to reach the site
of action, which means
it's the uncharged form
that's needed. So for
a drug that's, say,
50-50 rather than
1 to 1,000, just
to throw some
numbers out there.
The drug with a pKa of
7.5 is going to have
a much larger ratio
of the uncharged form
and therefore, well, a
greater amount of the
local anesthetic will
reach the cytoplasm.
Now,
this is important
for the onset of
action. In order
for the drugs to
start acting, It's
got to get there.
So it's got to
pass through.
And the amount of drug
that passes through
and gets to the site
of action in adequate
dose to block the
sodium channel is going
to have a faster onset
of action than the
drug that has a
smaller amount of the
uncharged form passing
through. the membrane.
Now, I have a practice
point over here
and it's related to
pH. We think about
the physiologic pH
being around 7.4.
In infected tissue,
the area is more
acidic. There's a lower
pH. So as the
extracellular pH goes more
acidic, the ratio
goes more towards the
charged form. So a
smaller amount of a
given drug will reach
the site of action.
So they're less
effective at that dose.
Now let's talk
about potency.
Potency is related
to lipid solubility.
Well why would that be?
Because the greater
the lipid solubility,
the greater the
affinity for the
lipid bilayer of
the nerve membrane.
Therefore, a greater
fraction of the
molecules in the dose
can enter the neurons.
So on the one side,
we have to think
about pKa and the
fraction of uncharted
form that's available
to pass through, but
it also has to be
lipid-soluble enough
to actually pass
through the membrane.
And the potencies are
different based on
their relative lipid
solubilities. So
procaine is the prototype,
and it was assigned
arbitrarily 1 as a
comparison point.
Chloroprocaine,
which I don't have a
star on, is almost
two times more potent.
******* is about
twice as potent.
Tetracaine is very,
very potent compared
to procaine. And
benzocaine is used
topically only, and
it's not very potent.
All right, so
these are the ester
linked. Remember
how the esterolinks
are metabolized.
That's the
pseudocolonesterase
in the plasma.
So they have a short
duration of action
largely because, one,
low potency, and two,
the rapid metabolism.
Tetrocaine is
an exception.
Tetrocaine is usually
given by spinal
anesthesia,
and there are little
to no, probably no,
pseudocolonesterase
in the
vicinity of
the injection.
And therefore, they
are highly potent,
and they have a long
duration of action.
Those are the takeaways
with tetrocaine.
As you can see,
it's unique features
compared to the
other estrelinked.
local anesthetics.
Let's take a look
at the amide link.
Lidocaine is
widely, widely used,
probably the
most widely used
local anesthetic
in the world.
It has a moderate
potency, so we'll
think about that
as four. It's
about four times
more potent than
procaine. These
are approximations.
and it has a
rapid onset and
a medium duration
of action.
Bupivacaine, I
don't have a star
on. It's similar
to lidocaine.
It's approximately
the same rate
of onset and
duration of action.
Prolocaine is,
again, in the same
kind of neighborhood
as lidocaine.
So, bupivacaine and
ropivacaine are
really potent.
Ropivacaine is slightly
less potent than
bupivacaine, which
becomes an important
idea later on. But
it's not a lot less
potent. We still
call it potent. And
they both have a long
duration of action.
High potency, long
Articane I put on
here just so we
remember that it
actually is in the group,
but I'm not going
to talk about
it. It's for
dental use only.
Duration of action
is determined by the
vascularity at the
injection site and
protein binding.
Now, I mentioned
before that metabolism
can influence it to
some extent, but
it is these two
features, vascularity
and protein binding,
that really determine
the duration of
action, because
what is the duration
of action? It's how
quickly the drug
is cleared from
the nerve. When the
drug moves out of the
site of application,
then the effect
is terminated.
So in areas of high
blood flow, the
local anesthetic
is quickly removed.
Makes sense,
right? So there's
a shorter duration
of action.
If a vasoconstrictor
is used, and it's
usually epinephrine,
which is present together
in the vial with the
local anesthetic,
then naturally the
local anesthetic is
going to stay around
a little bit longer.
So the duration
is increased.
Local anesthetics
bind plasma and
tissue proteins, I
mentioned before,
and of course,
sodium channel
proteins, that's
a side of action.
Protein-bound drugs
act as a reservoir.
They sequester
the drug, and the
drug will therefore
be moved from
those protein
-binding sites slowly.
Therefore,
highly lipid-soluble
drugs tend to bind
more tightly to
plasma and tissue
proteins, be retained
in the nerve membranes,
and get a longer
duration of action.
So to circle,
highly lipid-soluble
drugs have a longer
duration of action.
Follow me? Let's
talk about the mechanism,
but before we talk
about the mechanism,
we have to understand
about sodium channels
and how they work.
Voltage-gated sodium
channels exist in at
least three states.
We're thinking about
three for these local
anesthetics. The
resting state, you see
that in this picture.
The open and
activated state, we
see these little
dots rushing
through. Those
are sodium ions.
And it quickly
moves to the
inactivated state.
We talked about fast
inactivation
state previously.
And then it
will go back to
resting and so
on and so forth.
The local anesthetic,
I mentioned before,
needs to get into the
cytosol and it will
bind to the open and
inactivated channel.
There's a site inside
the sodium channel
where the drug will
bind, and that will
prolong this state,
the inactivated state.
So that's how they
work. By prolonging
the inactivated
state, that
reduces the high
frequency firing.
So let's get into
more details now about
the mechanism. I'll
do a little repetition
here. The non-ionized
form of the LA passes
through the nerve
membrane into the cytosol,
and once inside the
cytosol, it's going
to re-equilibrate into
its ionized and non
-ionized forms. And it
is the ionized form
that binds the
sodium channel in
the open and
inactivated state.
By doing so, it
stabilizes the fast
inactivation state,
accumulates block during
repetitive firing, and
binds more strongly
at depolarized potentials
with minimal effect
on the normal low
-frequency signaling.
I believe this sounds
very familiar to
you. This is the
description of the
mechanism of action
of the sodium channel
blockers that are
anti-seizure drugs.
State-dependent block
channels in the open
and activated state have
a much higher affinity
for the local anesthetic
than the channel
in the closed state,
closed resting state.
So what happens?
They enhance the fast
inactivation state
and just as a frame of
reference, recovery from
drug induced block is
ten to thousand times
slower than the recovery
of channels from the
normal inactivation.
So, stabilizing the
fast inactivation
state. That's our
state dependent block.
Use dependent block.
Rapidly firing nerves
are preferentially
blocked by the
local anesthetics.
Blockade is more
marked at higher
frequencies of
depolarization. So that's
this accumulating
block during
repetitive firing
is the use dependent
And voltage changes
causes changes in
the conformation
of the inner pore
during channel opening
and activation.
So that's voltage
-dependent gating.
The more positive
potentials, as in the
depolarized state,
increase the degree of
anesthetic block,
voltage-dependent block.
So, let's have a little
check your
knowledge quiz.
And I invite you to
pause your computer
and think about
these, maybe look
back if you don't
remember, and then
try and articulate
it without looking.
How do the pharmacokinetic
properties of
local anesthetics
influence clinical use?
That's why we care about
pharmacokinetic
properties.
The structural and
physicochemical
properties, well,
obviously the structure
will determine the
physicochemical
properties of the
drugs, influence
protein binding,
tissue distribution,
onset and duration
of action,
metabolism, and toxicity.
The ester-linked ones
are metabolized by
pseudocolonesterase,
so they tend to have
a shorter duration than
the amide ones. The
amide-linked are
metabolized in the liver,
so they tend to have
a longer duration.
How is the pKa of an LA
related to the
onset of action?
The drug with a pKa
closest to physiologic
pH will have a
greater proportion
of the molecule
in the uncharged
form, which is
necessary for passing
through the membrane
of the nerve cell.
Therefore, a higher
concentration
of the local
anesthetic is delivered
to the site of
action. Therefore,
there's a more
rapid onset.
How is the potency
of a local anesthetic
related to its
lipid solubility?
Highly lipid soluble
local anesthetics easily
diffuse through the
neuron membranes,
whereas *********** of
the less soluble drugs
is less efficient. Highly
lipid soluble local
anesthetics have a
greater affinity for the
nerve cell membrane and
also the surrounding
tissue proteins,
and let's not forget
plasma proteins. Thus,
a lower dose is needed
to produce an equivalent
effect. So back up.
Easily diffuse through
neuron membranes.
Where am I?
So a lower dose
is needed to
produce an
equivalent effect.
Plus they have a longer
duration of action.
What factors
determine the duration
of action of a
local anesthetic?
primarily determined
by how quickly the
drug is cleared from
the nerve or washed
out, that's called,
which depends on
the local blood flow,
vascularity, and
protein binding rather
than metabolism.
And how does this happen?
High blood flow
at the local site,
faster washout,
shorter duration.
We had a vasoconstrictor,
it slows it down.
Binding to tissue
proteins and also
plasma proteins
act as a reservoir
that slowly
releases the drug.
Highly lipid-soluble
drugs are bound
more tightly to tissue
proteins, retained
in the nerve membranes
also, therefore
there's a longer
duration of action.
which form of the
weak base binds to the
inner vestibule that's
the target of the
sodium channel and
prolongs the inactivation
phase remember the
ionized form what
are the components
of the mechanism of
action preferentially
binds the sodium
channel in the open
and inactivated state
stabilizes the fast
inactivation state,
accumulates block during
repetitive firing,
binds more strongly
at depolarized
potentials, with
minimal effect on
the normal low
-frequency signaling.
State-dependent,
use-dependent,
voltage-dependent block.
The rate of block
also depends on the
nerve sensitivity of
the different nerves.
because not all nerve
fibers are equally
affected by local
anesthetics. Some are
more sensitive, some
are less sensitive.
Sensitivity to
block is determined
by the diameter
of the fiber,
whether it's
tiny or larger,
the myelination
of the fiber, and
various other anatomic
and physiologic
factors. So
the tiny, rapid
-firing, sympathetic
fibers are first.
Then the small,
thinly myelinated and
unmyelinated fibers
that transmit pain
temperature and
light touch are next.
That's the
point of a local
anesthetic, is to
block the pain.
And then the
deep pressure and
finally the motor
function is lost,
is blocked.
And I put here
the various fiber
types. I'm not
going to be testing
you on specific B
fiber types, C fiber
types, A delta,
A beta, A alpha.
But you should
be aware of the
differential sensitivity
to blockade of
each of these sets
of neurons. There
are anatomical
factors involved as
well. I'm not going
into all of that.
so let's talk about
the effects of local
anesthetic toxicity
so when does toxicity
happen it happens
when the drug reaches
the bloodstream and
toxic doses so local
anesthetic systemic
toxicity, LAST, is a CNS
and cardiotoxic effect
of local anesthetics
that have been
systemically absorbed.
We'll talk
about transient
neurologic symptoms,
cauda equina syndrome,
methamoglobinemia,
and hypersensitivity.
Remember, as the
local anesthetics are
intended to remain
at the site of
injection. They're
not intended to be
introduced into the
systemic circulation.
So how does it get
there? Well it can occur
by inadvertent
vascular administration
or continuous
infusion. The
lidocaine actually
is an antiarrhythmic
given by continuous
infusion.
The example of the
intravenous nerve block,
what if the tourniquet
isn't tight enough?
That drug will go
straight into the system.
The rate and
extent of systemic
absorption are, as
I mentioned earlier,
determined by the
dose, the site of
administration, local
vascularity, presence of
a vasoconstrictor,
first pass extraction,
Sequestration
in muscle and
fat, plasma
protein binding,
and to some
extent, metabolism.
Now, I hope you
don't find this slide
too busy. I know
it's pretty busy, but
I tried to break
it up for you in a
way you can easily
see it. But I want
to keep the CNS toxicity
and cardiovascular
toxicity next
to each other so
that you always think
of them together.
because last
can be fatal.
And the danger, of
course, is related to
how much drug gets
into the bloodstream.
And here's a clinical
harbinger, a warning.
This is a warning.
CNS symptoms typically
appear before
cardiovascular collapse.
So if a patient
is starting to indicate
numbness around
his mouth and his
metallic taste and
feels dizzy, It should
be, uh-oh, we've
got drug going into
the bloodstream.
So early signs
of CNS toxicity,
which, as I
said, tends to
occur before the
cardiovascular,
are the perioral
numbness, so
the numbness
around the mouth,
this metallic
taste, dizziness,
nystagmus tinnitus.
And remember, the
sympathetic nervous system
is very sensitive to
local anesthetics. So the
outflow is transiently
increased as we
block sodium channels
in the inhibitory
interneurons. And then, as
the plasma concentration
increases, there
is a decrease in the
sympathetic outflow.
The sodium channels of
the preganglionic and
ganglionic sympathetic
nerves are blocked.
The greater degree of
CNS depression that
we see with the
larger amounts are
agitation and muscle
twisting. and then
that is followed by CNS
depression, myocardial
depression, and
death by respiratory
depression. So these
are CNS effects.
I want to draw your
attention here. So
this is a CNS
effect but it's the
cardiotoxic effect.
With the increase in
sympathetic outflow
initially the blood
pressure will go up
and the heart rate
will go up and then
that's followed by
Vasodilation,
hypotension, and
bradycardia. Add
to that the direct
effects of sodium
channel block on
the heart and
vasculature. Again,
hypotension
and bradycardia
from the direct effects.
Depression of
conduction velocity. and
in that pathway what
will occur is an
indirect decrease in
calcium influx and
calcium influx is
necessary for the heart
muscle to contract
so there will be
a decrease in myocardial
contractility.
Now on top of that the
local anesthetic can
diffuse into the
mitochondria and cause
mitochondrial dysfunction.
And what are the
mitochondria for?
They're our powerhouse.
They provide the energy.
So that gets interrupted.
And then what can
happen? Ventricular
arrhythmias and
cardiovascular collapse.
So I bring your attention
back to the
opening statement.
Well, fortunately,
we do have a reversal
agent, and it's
called intralipid,
IV intralipid
emulsion, and in case
you're interested
in doses, it's 20%.
This is a picture
of the bottle,
and there are
long-chain fatty
acids and other
things in there.
so there are a couple
of theories as to
how this lipid rescue
works by introducing
intralipid emulsion
and into the veins
intravenously that's
going to create
an expanded lipid
compartment obviously
and the local anesthetics
are lipophilic
they will partition
into the lipid
compartment And that
is referred to as lipid
sink. The drugs sink
into the lipids.
And redistribute,
so shuttled, they
get shuttled to the
liver for detoxification
and to the storage
organs. Wherever
the blood is going,
takes the drug
with them, the
lipid with the drug.
And there are
guidelines on how to
use this intralipid
for lipid rescue.
Well, what are
the relative risks
of LAS between
these various drugs?
So bupivacaine is by far
the most cardiotoxic.
Most cardiotoxic.
Why? Why? Because
high lipid solubility,
high protein
binding, plasma and
tissue proteins,
slow channel
dissociation, fast on,
slow off, and the
CNS warnings can be
brief or absent.
CNS equals CV, and I
said before, it's
generally the CNS that
occur first as a
warning, but with
bupivacaine, it
isn't necessarily so.
Now, ropivacaine, we
know that that's also
very potent. It is
slightly less potent
than bupivacaine, and
CNS effects are seen
before the cardiovascular
effects. So it
has lower cardiotoxicity.
This is not to say
it doesn't have
cardiotoxicity. It does.
It tends to be a
little bit less
lipid soluble with a
bit faster dissociation
rate from the
sodium channel.
Now,
lidocaine and
mipivacaine are moderate
CNS effects
well before the
cardiovascular
collapse because of the
faster sodium
channel dissociation.
They have this
wider safety margin.
And prolocaine has
the lowest risk,
wide safety margin,
rapid metabolism.
However, it can cause
methemoglobinemia,
cyanosis,
cyanosis, this is an
A, which can be fatal.
So, whereas it may
have a wide safety
margin in relation
to systemic toxicity,
it does cause
methemoglobinemia.
Now, these three others
are on this slide.
Notice that
it's lidocaine
spinal analgesia
for these two.
Transient neurologic
symptoms, TNS.
What is this? It occurs
pretty frequently.
I've read up to
a third of the
patients can
develop this with
lidocaine spinal
anesthesia.
Get this pain or burning.
It's really painful.
Prickly, achy sensation.
this is called
dysesthesia,
radiating from
the lower back and
gluteal region to
the posterior thighs.
It can be mild or
severe, and when
it's severe, it's
just unbearable.
It is not associated
with sensory
loss, motor weakness,
or bowel and
bladder dysfunction.
It is reversible,
and it generally
goes away by
itself within
several days.
serious and permanent
complications
after spinal anesthesia
with the lidocaine
are very rare
mapivacaine is another
one that occurs
with lower incidence
and it's not seen with
high frequency with
the other local
anesthetics i'm sure
there are case reports
but in general it's
much lower incidence.
Now, cauda equina
syndrome fortunately is
very rare, but because
it's irreversible,
that's why it's
fortunate it's very rare.
Compression of the
nerve root bundle
extending from the end
of the spinal cord will
produce this saddle
anesthesia or
paresthesia, meaning
the areas that would be
affected when you're
sitting on a saddle.
Urinary and *****
incontinence and
lower extremity
weakness can occur with
these. See how
different it is from
the transient
neurologic symptoms?
And methemoglobinemia.
Methemoglobinemia
occurs when the
iron within the
hemoglobin of red
blood cells is
converted to the ferric
form, which does
not bind oxygen.
So this toxic metabolite
of prolocaine called
otoluidine can lead
to methemoglobinemia.
And because it's not
binding oxygen, that
can lead to cyanosis
and death, potentially.
All dose-dependent,
of course.
Now benzocaine,
I mentioned, is
only, I don't know
if I mentioned it.
Benzocaine is only
used topically.
It's quite hydrophobic.
Look at that
PKA. However,
when used as an aerosol
spray for procedures
such as bronchoscopy,
endoscopy,
transesophageal
echocardiography, it is well
absorbed through mucous
membranes. It doesn't
absorb through skin
very well, but it does
absorb through mucous
membranes and it
will get into the systemic
circulation and it
forms toxic N
-hydroxyaromatic amines,
which in turn can lead
to methemoglobinemia.
And the advice from
our authorities is
to avoid benzocaine
in teething infants
and children's mouth
sores. those are
mucous membranes,
and we know that
benzocaine can be
absorbed through them.
Hypersensitivity.
Well, the ester local
anesthetics is
associated with a fairly
high degree of
hypersensitivity reactions
compared to other
types of drugs, and
this is related to
the metabolite paba.
It's the paba
that's causing
the hypersensitivity
reaction.
The amylocal
anesthetics has a
very low incidence.
Pregnancy, well we
always want to know
can we use the drug
in pregnancy and in
fact I'm sure you're
all aware that
local anesthetics are
widely used to manage
the pain during
labor and delivery.
It's given epidural,
spinal, depending
on the degree of
anesthesia that's needed,
labor or vaginal or
cesarean delivery.
The local
anesthetics that are
frequently used
are bupivacaine,
ropivacaine, tetracaine,
and possibly lidocaine.
now we talked
about epinephrine
being used
together with the
local anesthetic
to keep it
in place a little
longer but it should
not be used in
obstetrical patients
so think about this it
is a vasoconstrictor
vasoconstriction
can compromise
blood flow to the
uterus and placenta
and it can risk maternal
hypertension
tachycardia and
arrhythmia if it
does get absorbed
so i invite you
to pause the video
again and think
about these
questions look back
if you like and
then try and repeat
it from memory
what are the
manifestations of
local anesthetic
systemic toxicity
cns and cardiovascular
that should
jump right out at
you so early and late
that you should be
thinking about that, and
also remember sympathetic
nervous system.
So manifestations,
CNS, cardiovascular,
early, late, and
sympathetic
nervous system.
So the sympathetic
nervous system, the
sympathetic outflow
is transiently
increased as the
sodium channels on the
inhibitory interneurons
are blocked, and
then sympathetic
outflow is decreased.
Early symptoms, perioral
numbness, metallic
taste, dizziness,
tinnitus, nystagmus,
and then later,
agitation, muscle
twitching, CNS and
myocardial depression,
death usually by
respiratory depression.
And cardiovascular
effects, well we get the
CNS sympathetic effects,
and we know that
That reduced
sympathetic outflow plus
inhibition of sodium
channels on the preganglionic
and ganglionic
neurons will lead to
vasodilation, hypotension,
and bradycardia.
And then local anesthetics
can act directly
on cardiovascular
sodium channels to lead
to hypotension and
bradycardia through
that mechanism.
depression of conduction
velocity with indirect
decrease in calcium
influx into the
myocardial cells, and that
will decrease the
contraction of the heart
myocardial cells, and
then also the myocardial
dysfunction that
decreases the energy
output. I forgot to
mention that part of the
theory of the lipid
rescue is that it's
supplying these long
-chain fatty acids that
the mitochondria can
use to produce ATPs.
And the reversal agent,
intralipid. And I
should put that here.
long chain fatty acids.
Which LA is associated
with the highest
risk of cardiotoxicity?
Say it out loud.
Yes,
bupivacaine.
It strongly binds sodium
channels, dissociates
slowly, and CNS
and cardiovascular
toxicity can occur
almost simultaneously.
What are the cause
manifestations
and prognosis of TNS?
Transient neurologic
symptoms with
lidocaine spinal
anesthesia, so pain and
burning and prickly,
achy sensations.
It is not associated
with sensory loss,
motor weakness, or
bowel and bladder
dysfunction,
reversible, and usually
resolves by itself
within several days.
We see it also
with pivacaine,
but a lower incidence.
And cauda
equina syndrome,
lidocaine subarachnoid
administration,
that's spinal anesthesia,
can very rarely
lead to irreversible
compression of
the nerve root
bundle extending from
the end of the spinal
cord, which can
lead to urinary and
***** incontinence and
lower extremity
weakness and that's
saddle area, paresthesias
and numbness.
And what are
the causes and
effects of
methemoglobinemia?
prolocaine and benzocaine
and the LA's with
the highest incidence
of hypersensitivity
reactions the ester
linked and that brings us
to the individual
drugs chloroprocaine is
not starred because
its activity is really
pretty much the same as
procaine but procaine
is not on the market
anymore. Chloroprocaine
is. So it's very rapid
acting, very rapid
onset, and short
duration of action. Those
are the takeaways with
chloroprotein. Ester,
pseudoclonesterase
metabolism.
So you know.
Tetrocaine, *******.
Tetrocaine because
it's very important in
clinical use. *******
because it's actually
still used as a local
anesthetic. Benzocaine
for the reasons
that we saw earlier.
Lidocaine because it's
the local anesthetic.
Prolocaine because of
the methemoglobinemia.
Mepivacaine is pretty
much like lidocaine,
so I'm not including
a star on that.
And bupivacaine or
opivacaine, I think
you can see why it's
important to know
those. So let's start
with the estralink.
Procaine, chloroprocaine,
tetracaine,
and benzocaine, these
are all synthetic.
Pseudocholinesterase,
metabolism,
rapid hydrolysis,
so it's less than
a minute, so you
can imagine how
short the duration
of action is.
2-PAPA. um
patients who have
reduced or absent plasma
cholinesterase
because of a genetic
single nucleotide
polymorphism those drugs
will not be metabolized
as rapidly so
they can accumulate
and the therefore we
might see the same
types of toxicities
we see with the other
amide linked ones.
And then we have our paba
hypersensitivity
reactions.
I included here a
reminder that spinal fluid
contains a little or
no esterase so the
effect of tetracane for
spinal administration,
spinal anesthesia is
going, plus the fact that
it's highly potent,
it will stay around
for quite some time,
long duration of action.
******* is a
natural product.
It is metabolized by
pseudocolonesterase
and also hepatic
esterases
to a toxic n
-hydroxyaromatic
amines.
some other features
of this group of
drugs manufacturing
discontinued well if
it's not manufactured
anymore why do i
need to know it it is
the prototype it is
the drug to which
everything else was
compared it prototype
means it was the
first one you may
have heard of it is
Novocaine. It was widely
used in dentistry.
You can read these
for yourselves. This
is everything that
I've been saying.
Chloroprocaine,
same deal.
Tetracaine I put in
a shade here. This
happens to be a light
green shade because
it's for spinal
anesthesia, highly
lipophilic, high
potency, long-acting, and
there is significant
toxicity potential when
used for high volume
peripheral block.
Benzocaine topical
only, rapid absorption
from mucous
membranes, but poorly
absorbed from the
skin, comes in various
topical forms,
including that aerosol
spray I mentioned
before, very low pKa.
And it can cause
met hemoglobinemia
when systemically
absorbed. *******,
all right, what do
we use this for?
Topically for
nose, mouth, and
pharynx procedures,
this is why.
These are highly
vascular tissues and
******* has an intrinsic
vasoconstriction
action. So epinephrine
isn't even needed.
Rapid onset, short
acting, and of
course, ******* has
the ***** potential.
The amides,
lidocaine,
rapid onset,
moderate potency,
moderate duration
of action,
hepatic CYP metabolites,
metabolism to the
xylodide metabolites.
You should remember
the xylodides. They
are active. They also
go into the CNS and
can contribute to last.
They're not as potent
as lidocaine, but
they can still block
sodium channels.
So that's why you
need to remember
these xylodide
metabolites,
plus the others
don't have them.
This may become an
issue when lidocaine is
used intravenously as
an anti-arrhythmic.
And lots and lots
and lots of uses.
Prilocaine really
is only used
topically here in
the United States.
Now,
prilocaine is mixed
together with lidocaine.
They're both solids,
and when you mix them
together, it causes
the melting point to
go down, and they turn
into a topical cream.
Mepivacaine, rapid
onset, moderate
potency, moderate
duration,
hepatic metabolism,
so pretty much the
same as lidocaine. It's
used in dental
anesthesia quite a bit.
Bupivacaine, rapid onset,
high potency,
long duration,
hepatic CYPs,
metabolites out in the
urine. You see this
pattern here? You don't
have to remember every
single one, every
single individual
drug, because it's
pretty much the same
all the way through.
You do have to
know what it's
used for, local,
regional, and
norexial
anesthesia mainly.
A low dose is good
pain management.
Higher dose,
we start to see
the sensory and
motor block.
Rupivacaine, same
thing. It's pretty much
the same as bupivacaine.
We remember, though,
that it seems to be
a little bit safer
because the cardiotoxicity
does occur after
the CNS toxicity
symptoms are manifest.
Artecanum, just
dental anesthesia.
So toxicities, they
can all cause local
anesthetic systemic
toxicity. The
degree of severity of
the toxicity Depends
on the dose and on
the drug itself.
And then there's the
lipid rescue that
will bind up that
drug, bring it into the
lipid, and move it
around. Move it to
the liver, move it to
the storage organs.
Bupifacaine is the
most cardiotoxic.
You can never say
that too much.
Lidocaine, we see the
transit neurologic
symptoms, and the
quadokina, and prolocaine,
the methemoglobinemia.
So this slide
is really a reminder
of the others, and
I'm putting it here
because I want to
make sure that you
understand the toxicities
of these drugs. It's
worth repeating.
And summary. I'm not
going to read the
summary to you. This
is everything we've
been talking about.
Hopefully this summary
is arranged in a
way that will help
you. And then we have
your answers to the
Check Your Knowledge
questions and hope
you remain pain-free.
That concludes
this lecture.